thank you for the introduction so as
james mentioned my name is griffin dietz
and in my work i integrate perspectives
from hci cognitive development education
and ai to design and develop cognitively
appropriate
computing education platforms for young
learners
so in recent years we've seen a global
push for computing education for all
children for whom this early exposure
can lead to increased interest in the
field
the development of computational
thinking and literacy skills and
computing readiness to support an entire
educational career
and with growing influence and
prevalence of ai and machine learning in
everyday life we see both new
opportunities for delivering educational
content that leverages ai
and new obligations to educate young
learners about this kind of technology
that they interact with every day
continue to do so more and more
but there remains a lack of ai supported
computing education tools
a number of computing education tools do
exist but many students still lack
access because those tools don't meet
the cognitive needs of the learners
for example surrounding literacy or
problem solving skills
these tools run on expensive specialized
hardware
that families or school districts are
unable to afford
the tools are ineffective without
educator support
or the tools cover out-of-date content
compared to the state of the art and
computing
i believe that we can address these gaps
in access by taking an interdisciplinary
approach to the design and development
of computing education platforms
by first studying the developmental
capacities of young learners to engage
with this content
and then designing and developing
appropriate tools that directly address
these findings we can build software
systems to support accessible computing
education
specifically today i'll argue that
cognitively appropriate and readily
accessible computing education tools
support children's engagement and
learning of core ideas in computing
but what do i mean by that by
cognitively appropriate i mean meeting
the cognitive limits of users for
example surrounding literacy or
problem-solving skills
while still designing for the
competencies that they do have as
illustrated in contemporary cognitive
development literature
by readily accessible i mean running on
widespread general purpose hardware like
smartphones or tablets which earn 97 of
american homes
rather than on specialized equipment
like robots or tangible coding tools
and by core ideas and computing i mean
both the key concepts of software
development like sequences loops or
events and the key practices of computer
science like planning decomposition
abstraction or iterative development
i'll provide evidence for this argument
across two domains of computing
education computational thinking and
artificial intelligence
and i will show how we can leverage
conversational ai to create new
paradigms in computing education
how we might extend this voice-based
approach into a multimodal system
how children began to think about and
conceptualize this kind of voice-based
ai
and how we can build on top of existing
infrastructures in computing education
to educate students about ai
so starting with computational thinking
i'll demonstrate how we can teach
computational thinking concepts to
pre-literate children through
storytelling using a voice guided system
called story coder
so despite a recent emphasis on
computing education for all many of our
youngest learners lack the advanced
literacy numeracy or fine motor skills
needed to use most traditional
programming environments or
computational thinking tools
a number of successful solutions for
young children seek to bypass these
literacy requirements
but these approaches often depend on a
knowledgeable teacher for students to
make meaningful progress in the case of
block-based programming environments
or they require expensive and
specialized technologies that are not
readily available to all students in the
case of tangibles or programmable robots
and although these tools support
children's engagement with computing
concepts
they often lack scaffolding for key
practices like decomposition
this design leads to bottom-up
development and non-reusable
fine-grained code both of which are
contrary to accepted practices in
computing
but why is this the case
as it stands many of the computer
science education tools today are
informed by piagettian psychology
which suggests that children cannot
reason abstractly until they're much
older around age 12.
but my own work into children's
capacities for problem decomposition
joins a growing body of literature in
the cognitive development space and
telling another story about children's
abstract reasoning skills
we leveraged a block building paradigm
and we asked children to reconstruct
target structures from components
and we showed that contrary to prior
belief
decomposition skills do begin to develop
by early elementary years
we therefore aim to directly support
children's engagement with decomposition
and abstraction while still introducing
computing concepts like sequences and
loops
so in this project i demonstrate that
children can learn computational
thinking concepts in a way that
simultaneously builds literacy skills by
engaging with these ideas through
storytelling
and further aligning with the oral
traditions of storytelling it's possible
to introduce these computing concepts
using a smartphone-based voice interface
which allows even pre-literate children
to engage with this material without
necessitating any specialized hardware
finally we do so in a way that scaffolds
decomposition and abstraction while
children learn computing concepts
from a curricular standpoint we pulled
our computational learning goals from
brennan and resnick's 2012 computational
thinking definition which was developed
for elementary school learners using
scratch
and from the k-12 cs framework
so cross-referencing these lists we
identified four key computing concepts
sequences loops
events and data or variables and four
key computing practices decomposition
abstraction planning and computing for
self-expression
from a storytelling perspective prior
work has shown that early exposure to
storytelling can improve children's
reading writing listening and oracy
skills later in life
and specifically reading children aloud
reading stories aloud to children and
explicitly teaching them story structure
improves language comprehension and
reading comprehension skills later on
so we aimed to support these activities
as well
to also ensure that our solution was
grounded in the needs of teachers and
learners we engaged in needfinding
we conducted semi-structured interviews
with 11 participants and two classroom
observations as pictured in this photo
on the right and through this formative
investigation we identified three key
design objectives beyond these
curricular goals
first we found a need to make tools
accessible to children in terms of
literacy
for children who are non-readers and
financially
we turn to voice interaction to support
these young pre-literate learners in
expressing complex or abstract ideas
and we built a system that could run on
general purpose hardware
smartphones
we found a need to make tools
approachable to children educators and
parents who might be experiencing
self-doubt and their ability to learn or
teach about computing
we aim to make our solution approachable
even to reticent learners by using
storytelling as a really familiar domain
by which to teach these computing
concepts
and finally educators mentioned a need
for long-term engagement
they suggested the personally meaningful
projects could drive these engage this
engagement by allowing students to get
invested in what they're actually
working on
we therefore gave children agency about
the kinds of stories that they could
tell to ensure the system connects to
their interests
putting this all together we built story
coder a voice-based smartphone
application that introduces computing
concepts to children through
storytelling
games story coder consists of six voice
based user flows two targeting
storytelling which guide children in
creating and listening to stories and
four story games that each use
storytelling as a domain to learn about
a specific computational concept
so child might begin by engaging with
the create a story flow
so in this flow the app scaffolds
decomposition and abstraction as the
child generates a story plan
it does so by asking about the main
character the location and the problem
and the story
and then it encourages the child to tell
the story with a beginning a middle and
an end
let's make a story plan i'm going to ask
four questions question one is the star
of your story a person or animal
[Music]
animal awesome what kind of animal
a dog
sounds good we'll tell a story about a
dog
so once a child has created their story
they can listen to it or they can play
with that story to engage with key
computing concepts sequences loops
events and variables through one of four
computational story games
for example in word events a child can
pick a word and their story to be an
event which can then trigger recorded
sound effects
awesome we will record a sound effect
for the word event clue
you can record any kind of noise as soon
as you tap on the microphone start
recording your noise
[Music]
whenever we hear the word flute we'll
play the sound
so every user flow underwent a design
process that included wizard of oz
testing prior to implementation
and iterative testing after development
to further improve our system's design
we then conducted an evaluation of the
system with 22 children age five to
eight
half of these children were female and
half were male with seven entering
kindergarten and five entering each of
first through third grade
children came from eight different u.s
states had reading levels ranging from
pre-reader to early fluency
and had no prior exposure to computer
science
each child participated in four
60-minute sessions over zoom on four
consecutive days
so on the first day we dedicated the
session to app setup and pre-assessment
on the second and third day children
played with the story coder app
and on the fourth and final day we
completed post assessment
we specifically sought to answer eight
research questions that related to our
overarching objectives in the
development of story comprehension
computational learning and attitudinal
shifts towards computing for today i'm
just going to go over two of these in
detail one related to storytelling and
one related to computing
so beginning with storytelling we asked
do children tell better stories with the
scaffolding provided by the system
we asked children to tell three stories
over the course of the study
first in pre-assessment they told us a
story without any constraints which we
called the free storytelling condition
so we asked them tell us a story about
anything
also in pre-assessment they told us a
story in which we verbally provided the
same constraints that they received from
the guidance in the app
which we call the constrained
storytelling condition
and finally children told the story
during gameplay or in-app condition
so we asked if the planning activity or
the constraints provided therein would
help children to tell better stories
overall
we scored these stories by using the
index of narrative complexity which is a
13 item rubric that was designed as a
progress monitoring tool so to compare a
child's stories to their own former
stories
and what we found is that children told
significantly better stories with the
planning guidance provided by our app
than they did without such guidance
so we see that stories told in
pre-assessment without any planning
scaffolding are on the left
and we can see the increase in scores
and planned stories on the right
i'll note though that this effect is
specific to older children
this might be because the majority of
the younger age group had yet to even
start kindergarten
with the beginning of formal schooling
we see a rise in related skills like
planning or auditory memory so the lower
scores in that group might be as a
result of this
looking next computing we also ask can
children recognize the computing
concepts in the new context specifically
scratch animations
so for this recognition task we first
explained that my friend sarah made a
new game except and her game taught the
same four ideas as story coder
except her game uses animations instead
of stories
another child johnny played this
animation game
he picked an animation to start with and
then he changed it just a little bit as
he was playing
so we played children up before
animation and then after animation and
we asked them which game had cellini
played
we ran eight trials two covering each
concept where one of those trials was a
near transfer example of that concept
and the other one was a farther transfer
example relative to the presentation of
that concept in the app
and we'll report percent correct here
if a child had learned nothing we might
expect that their responses would
resemble the responses of a child who
was guessing
they would show chance level performance
which here is denoted by this dotted
blue line
overall though we found that children
were able to recognize the four
computing concepts
both younger and older age groups
performed significantly above chance on
this concept recognition task
so in this work we developed story coder
and through it we showed that
preliterate children
can use a conversational voice interface
to effectively learn computational
thinking concepts through storytelling
games
story coder demonstrated the potential
for voice interfaces and delivering
educational content
but it also came with its own set of
challenges
so we continued on to build a more
robust multi-modal extension of the
system which we're calling visual story
coder
so in this follow-up we developed a
system that supported the creation of
more complex stories and also included
more concrete learner engagement around
computing practices like decomposition
and abstraction
story coder showed that voice interfaces
can be successful in delivering
instruction
but voice interaction also presents
challenges to cognitive load and
navigation which can prevent the
creation of more complex stories
to use a voice only app a child needs to
remember everything that they've already
done in order to decide what to do next
and if they want to navigate elsewhere
or go back it's a lot easier to do that
by pressing a button than it is to
navigate by voice
block based programming interfaces on
the other hand present continuous cues
and reminders through a graphical
interface
but these interfaces can suffer from a
lack of built-in instruction
which can make it hard for children to
succeed without access to educator
support
so we developed visual story coder a
multimodal system that blends the
strengths of these approaches to
overcome their respective weaknesses
this system more actively engages
children with decomposition and
abstraction while also supporting the
creation of more complex stories
so this system is aided by flow the fish
which is an instructional voice agent
you see in the top left
this child has completed the planning
process she's about to start telling her
story so we can watch her make her first
chapter
i'm excited to hear your story about a
it's about a basketball player
after
a basketball court
hit the check mark to get started
awesome our story will have at least
three chapters a beginning a middle and
an
end
and to get started drag a dark green
chapter block into our workspace just
like in books our chapters will hold
pages pages are where we'll add words
and pictures to our story we can add
pages to a chapter with a page block
great every page should have both words
and pictures tap on that page to start
editing
oh
in the beginning we talk about the star
and the location of the story can you
tell me the beginning of your story this
is about it
[Laughter]
awesome now let's draw a picture for
this page of your story you can drag
stamps of the star location and problem
into the picture for this page or you
can use the toggle to switch to draw
mode
thanks for telling me about the
beginning of your story when you're done
with the beginning tap on the smiley
face on this chapter and save it by
choosing an emoji
now that your chapter is saved we can
add it to your story your story is at
the bottom of the screen tap the plus
button to add a chapter to the story and
select the emoji for the beginning
chapter
so through this interface a learner
specifically engages with abstraction
and decomposition by modeling their
story
or modeling their program as a story and
then by breaking that story down into
chapters and chapters into pages
by defining chapters with emojis and
then including those chapters in the
main story they're engaging with
activities akin to defining functions
and then calling those functions from
their programs
once they've created their full story
they can again engage with loops events
and variables
for example they can turn the stamps
that they included in their story's
pictures into variables and change them
out for new pictures
so this girl decided that it was obvious
that her story about a basketball player
took place at a basketball court and she
wanted to be more specific so she
changed her location so her story took
place at a basketball center rather than
at school for example
a variable is a thing that can change
but we can only change one thing for
another of the same type
we can make the picture stamps in your
story into variables
now can you draw a new picture of the
location
cool now you're using a variable in your
story we have changed out the stamp
anytime you used it in your story
pictures
and then we can see that change manifest
in her story pictures wherever she used
that location stamp
so we conducted a between subject's
evaluation of the system with 24
children age six to eight
half of them use visual story coder and
half of them use scratch junior which is
a leading block based programming app
for this age group
six first graders and six second graders
participated in each of these conditions
and none of these children had any prior
instruction in computer science
children participated in two 60-minute
sessions over zoom on two consecutive
days on the first day they independently
played with the app
the experimenter wasn't allowed to
provide any support or answer any
questions
on the second day the child received
instructions on four concepts in the app
those four concepts were the same across
all children but the instruction was
rooted in the project that they'd
created on day one
then they had another 30 minutes to
create a brand new project except this
time they were allowed to ask questions
so before going further i do want to
lend some context to this comparison
in visual story coder children program
stories using chapter and page blocks
and an agent provides just-in-time
instruction
in scratch junior children program
animations by controlling the motion of
characters using code blocks
there's a tutorial video in the app
which all children in this condition
watched at the start of session 1 but
there's otherwise little built-in
support
through this comparison we look to
answer three key research questions
related to our overarching objectives in
supporting at-home learning through
built-in instruction and an emphasis on
computing practices
so we asked does built-in instruction
and a focus on decomposition and
abstraction affect the degree of system
understanding among users and the
quality of code artifacts that they
produce
does experimenter instruction and
question answering in session two impact
the system understanding and code
quality
and how engaging do children find these
two systems
again for today i'm just gonna go over
two of these so we'll talk about system
understanding and code quality
so we looked at two quantitative metrics
and two qualitative metrics to answer
these questions
first we evaluate the degree of
understanding of key aspects of the
system
scored from a rubric based on a post
session quiz
we also quantified the quality of the
code artifacts that children produced
based on a rubric for scoring scratch
junior projects this rubric was pulled
from prior work then we created a direct
mapping adaptation of that rubric to
score the visual story photo projects
we collected qualitative data from
experimenter observations during
gameplay
and from an artifact-based interview at
the end of each session in which we
asked children about the projects that
they'd made
so looking at our data we see an
unsurprising significant effect of
system understanding by session
so as you see here we see an increase in
system understanding in the second
session
after children have had an opportunity
to familiarize themselves with the app
after they've received instruction and
after they've had a chance to ask
questions
and i'll note that here and on all
graphs in this presentation error bars
are 95 confidence intervals
interestingly though we also see a
significant interaction between app and
session
children using scratch junior had a much
larger increase in understanding from
session one to session two
whereas this was not so much the case
with visual story coder where the change
in system understanding after
instruction was much smaller
we interpret this as support for the
ability of built-in instruction to teach
a child about a system a visual story
coder whereas scratch jr really
benefited from that instruction educator
support
qualitatively participants spoke about
how the instruction was important to
them
and figuring out how to use the app so
when asked what they did when they got
stuck one eight-year-old using
storycoder said
it was important for me to know to click
on the fish when i didn't know what to
do of course in our app clicking on the
fish would make it repeat its
instructions
on the other hand children using scratch
jr talked about being confused clicking
about randomly when they didn't know
what to do or just ignoring the parts
that they didn't understand
different eight-year-old said when i was
confused with something i kind of just
ignored it and did something different
based on this qualitative data we
believe that built-in instruction was
critical to the system understanding in
visual story coder
next we look at code quality across
sessions
we find that the average code quality
for visual story coder is higher but not
to a statistically significant degree
when aggregated across sessions
but we also see a great deal of variance
and code quality scores in session one
in scratch there were children who
didn't touch the code blocks at all and
there were children who dragged every
single code block possible into their
projects just to see what they would do
our rubric was based on the presence of
code blocks and projects so that
contributed to a lot of variants in
scratch jr
in storycoder we had multiple children
who didn't get through the full user
flow of the app in the allotted 30
minutes because they spent so much time
telling their stories
this means that they didn't get a chance
to engage with loops events or variables
which also means that these concepts
weren't present in their projects in
this first session
so as a follow-up we look only to
session two when students have
familiarized themselves with the app and
what it can do
and we find that students using visual
story coder do create statistically
higher quality stories
we attribute some of this difference to
the app scaffolding around planning
children using visual story coder talked
about the need to plan their stories
whereas those using scratch jr often
mentioned making up their story as they
went along
when asked how they got their idea for
their project one six-year-old using
storyteller said
i got started by thinking who was in the
book and then i was like thinking about
what they would do and it was important
for me to have a plan
on the other hand one seven-year-old
using scratch jr said
i went to like the plus button and i saw
a really pretty flower and i wanted it
to be part of my story so then i thought
of that but i technically made it up as
i went
differences in this reported planning
behavior provide evidence for how visual
story coder can support children's
planning processes
so overall with visual story coder we
demonstrated how multi-modal interfaces
with built-in instruction
help learners better apply computational
thinking practices
shifting gears now to look to the domain
of ai education we first ask how young
learners intuitively think about
conversational ai like the kind they
interacted with in story coder
so when we were developing story coder
we time and again heard stories from
parents about their children's
interactions with conversational ai
there was a four-year-old who when told
his entire family was going on vacation
asked is google coming to
and there was a three-year-old whose
family had a korean rice cooker and
every time the rice was ready it would
say in korean the rice is ready and this
three-year-old would go running over to
the rice cooker to talk to her grandma
the only korean speaker in her life
so with virtual assistants everywhere we
begin to question when a young child
begins to interact with this kind of
technology
what is it they think they're talking to
and how do they extend their cognitive
capacities for reasoning about other
human minds in order to reason about
this kind of ai
so we know that humans have robust
systems for identifying living and
non-living for distinguishing between
agents and objects
and for reasoning about the minds of
other humans
but conversational ai falls into this
unusual psychological pocket of
exhibiting many of the key behaviors of
living agents and humans in particular
while being distinctly non-living
objects
by preschool children's speech is
coherent enough for them to begin
interacting with conversational ai
at this point children have a robust
understanding that agents are goal
directed and have internal responses to
external behavior
they're also beginning to understand
that agents can have knowledge separate
from themselves
and beliefs that differ from ground
truth which both influence this
goal-directed behavior
and further prior work has shown how
children extend this reasoning to
non-human agents
but it remains unclear
what of this intuitive psychology
might they leverage in interactions with
conversational ai
and how might they use these cognitive
capacities to build mental models around
this kind of ai more broadly
limited prior work exists in this space
but in one study
children aged three to six interacted
with google home for a brief period
before being asked to draw google
notably before age six
some of those drawings contained a
human-like feature
like eyes or mouth
here we see that one child said google
is a girl but she doesn't have any arms
after age six though none of those
drawings contained any human-like
elements
so we initially piloted a similar task
and we found similar trends
but the study doesn't ultimately help us
understand how children represent the
mental states of these devices to reason
about their behavior
so we ask how do children reason about
the minds of virtual assistants
one possibility is that children reason
about these devices in the same way that
they'd reason about human minds before
they be begin to distinguish the nuances
of these devices from the minds of
people
so let's look at how children reason
about the minds of people
this paradigm in particular rests
heavily on something called false belief
so let me first explain that
as an example
this is rachel rachel brought raisins to
have during snack time
rachel's in a room with two containers
and rachel decides to put her raisins in
the blue container
then rachel goes away
now while rachel is away joe comes in
joe decides to play a trick on rachel
joe takes rachel's raisins out of the
blue container and moves them to the
green container
and then
joe goes away
so now
rachel comes back in
where will rachel look for her raisins
the blue container or the green
container
hopefully you all realize that in this
scenario joe
knows that the raisins are in the green
container but rachel
falsely believes the raisins are in the
blue container
adults would understand that these two
people have separate minds with separate
information
adults would answer blue container
your average three-year-old though would
answer green container
because three-year-olds typically fail
to represent others false beliefs
this comprehension of false belief is a
key marker in children's understanding
of others minds that we build upon in
our study
so what does the developmental
trajectory of false belief understanding
look like
something like this
three-year-olds typically fail false
belief tasks
they give responses consistent with the
understanding that rachel and joe share
a mind
they would say that rachel would look
for her raisins in the green container
in the years following though we see a
sharp increase in understanding
such that children demonstrate adult
level performance on these false belief
tasks by age six
six year olds would give answers
consistent with the understanding that
people have separate minds
and they would say that rachel would
look for her raisins in the blue
container
so returning to our question we asked
how do children reason about the minds
of virtual assistants
or more specifically how do children
extend their false belief reasoning to
reason about virtual assistants
so we present to children with a false
belief task
so here
scotty and the dark blue shirt goes into
a room and tells one person that his
favorite song is the itsy bitsy spider
then he goes into a different room and
tells a different person that actually
his favorite song is the wheels on the
bus
and finally he returns to the first room
and asks that first person can you
please play my favorite song
our key question is what song will this
person play
hopefully you all say this person will
play the itsy bitsy spider the first
song because that's what scotty told
this first person in this first room was
his favorite song even though he later
corrected that information for a
different agent
your average three-year-old though would
say that this person would play the
wheels on the bus because of their lack
of understanding of false beliefs
now
imagine that scotty was talking to smart
speakers instead
the interaction is the same
what song would the first speaker play
the answer maybe isn't as clear
but if these two devices are in the same
household and connected to the same
account you might infer that the first
smart speaker would actually have the
updated information given to the second
smart speaker and play the second song
the wheels on the bus
turns out adults understand this so here
we ran the study online with 59 adults
on prolific and we plot the proportion
of adults in each condition answering
with each song
in our person condition in gray adults
say that the person in the first room
will play the itsy bitsy spider the
first song
but in the a.i condition in blue
we see that adults say that the smart
speaker in that first room will play the
second song the wheels on the bus
a replication of the study yields the
same results
adult responses and the person condition
are consistent with the understanding
that people have separate minds
but in the ai condition responses are
consistent with the understanding that
smart speakers have a shared mind or a
connected back end
so we've also run 135 children age 3 to
8 through this task conducted remotely
over zoom
as a reminder i've plotted adult level
performance as points here on the right
again the person condition is gray and
the ai condition is blue
so what do children do
looking first to the person condition we
see that our data follows the false
belief trajectory that i previously
showed
three-year-olds are answering
incorrectly on this task because of
their failure to reason about false
beliefs but by age six children are
demonstrating adult level performance
and giving responses consistent with the
understanding that people have separate
minds
turning to the ai condition we might
expect the curve to look something like
this green curve that i've drawn on the
graph
children might start in a similar place
with a lack of representation of false
beliefs
the curve might be bend upward as
children begin to understand false
belief
but it should ultimately end up down at
the bottom somewhere near adult level
understanding
looking at our data though we see that
in the ai condition if we first look at
children who do not have connected smart
speakers at home
their responses again follow the false
belief trajectory
children in this group have not begun to
differentiate the mental states of these
devices from those of people
perhaps because they've not had enough
experience with these devices to start
building separate mental models
but if we look to children that do have
connected smart speakers at home
we see that even children with extensive
experience with these devices
don't give answers that anywhere
resembles adult level understanding
so this is an example of ai that these
children do interact with
but we undoubtedly see a clear
difference in understanding between even
eight-year-olds and adult-level
performance
so returning once more to our research
questions we find that children's
reasoning about the mental states of
these devices follows in line with their
reasoning about humans at least through
age 8 in this false belief task
experience with connected smart speakers
at home may have some impact on this
understanding
but adult level understanding doesn't
emerge until sometime between age 9 and
18.
therefore this work demonstrates that
children's misunderstandings of ai
systems
suggests a need for ai education
that helps to facilitate more accurate
mental model development
which leads me to the last project that
i'll discuss today an accessible system
for ai education
and i do want to mention here that this
next section contains work i did while
working at apple
so conversational ai is just one example
of the kinds of systems ai driven
systems that kids might interact with
with the increasing prevalence of ai and
machine learning in everyday life
we see that researchers and educators
have started advocating
for studying ai machine learning
education as a complement to
contemporary computing education
today robotics is one of the main entry
points to computing but while
state-of-the-art robotics makes heavy
use of ai and machine learning k-12
robotics education today centers on
mechanical engineering and imperative
programming
this makes robotics an ideal context for
introducing ai and machine learning to
students
in particular robotics is a natural fit
for exploring reinforcement learning
which is a type of machine learning used
in state-of-the-art robotics research
but reinforcement learning also drives
some of today's day-to-day ai
technologies that young children might
be interacting with
reinforcement learning has been less
studied in the ai education space but we
also hypothesize it's conceptually easy
comparatively to understand
although robotics is relatively
widespread the cost of specialized
hardware can be a huge barrier to access
so we also aim to create a more
accessible robotics education by
leveraging virtual robots that run on
general purpose hardware tablets and
then bringing these robots to life using
augmented reality
so in our work we built autonomous a
robotics education experience for middle
school students that addresses cost
barriers to wider implementation by
leveraging general purpose hardware
and tests our conjecture that young
learners can develop a conceptual
understanding of reinforcement learning
to make sure we're all on the same page
i'll go over the concept behind
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a machine
learning training method based on
rewarding desired behaviors and
penalizing undesired ones or in other
words it's learning from rewards and
penalties
imagine training a dog
if a dog does something good you might
give it a reward like a treat
it does something bad you might get a
give it a penalty like scolding it
over time that dog might become more or
less likely to take a similar action in
a similar situation
in the context of robotics we can train
a robot robot to navigate using
simulations one that does something good
we can give it points
when it does something bad we'll take
away points
in the autonomous app students use
reinforcement learning to train
autonomous navigation models that
integrate with event driven code
allowing the user to customize their
robot's behavior
users are able to create tracks for
their robots
train virtual robot agents to navigate
these tracks using reinforcement
learning
view simulations and visualizations of
that training
and combine their models with code for
flexible closed-loop robotics
so for the purposes of a demo let's
imagine that the student had this
objective
they wanted a school bus robot to
navigate autonomously around a bus route
track
it should stop flash its lights and load
passengers at every one of the red bus
stops
and it should stop unload all its
passengers again flashing its lights at
the yellow school bus stop at the bottom
so our user here has already recreated
this bus route track in the app
and they start with a partially
pre-trained robot
that means that if we test this current
robot on the bus route track we'll see
that it knows it should be moving
forward but it's not very good at
following the track yet especially on
tight turns
going back we can create a track to
train our robot on the target's an issue
that we've identified so the square
track gives the robot practice on those
tight turns
so we save the track and kick off that
training
training can take some time so speaking
speeding it up a bit here we see that
the car does get better over time
and on episode 50 it actually does
pretty good
so next we can bring this experience to
life and check out a simulation of that
50th episode in augmented reality
finally returning to our bus route track
for another test run now that we've done
some training we see that our robot does
better
but we also see that it still has some
training to do
once students have a working model they
can switch over to the code editor which
will load up the course and the robot
navigation model on the right
and present users with the development
environment on the left
this interface contains a function
library that students can use to
customize robot behavior during event
driven callbacks
for example they could change the
robot's color to yellow at the start of
the run or flash lights and pick up a
passenger at a pickup point
we evaluated this experience in
90-minute remote sessions with 15 middle
school students age 11 to 14.
six of these students were female
9 were male and all of these students
had prior experience with robotics or
hardware
after an introductory phase students
trained a robot to navigate and wrote
code to achieve that school bus
objective that i showed in the demo
we then concluded with about 10 minutes
of questions and feedback
so we measured participants developing
understanding of reinforcement learning
their engagement with the apps and their
curiosity to learn more about machine
learning
across several measures we found that
participants developed an understanding
of reinforcement learning
for example when asked what
reinforcement learning is
93 percent of participants described
reinforcement learning as an agent
learning from rewards penalties or
experiences for future novel situations
for example one 12-year-old said about
reinforcement learning it's when you
have something do something and it takes
your input and it does an action and
then you give it like points or not
points or whatever so that knows when it
did something wrong and when it did
something right
so they can try to do the right thing
next time
looking at participants engagement we
took the seven prompts from the giggle
gauge metric which is a validated
self-report engagement metric from prior
work
participants indicated their agreement
with each prompt on a scale from one to
seven and we report a mean engagement
score of 6.17 out of 7 which indicates
relatively high engagement
from a curiosity standpoint
we asked students their level of
agreement with the statement i would
like to learn more about reinforcement
learning
here they report a mean score of 6.47
out of 7 and all children gave a score
of 5 or greater indicating that they all
agreed with this statement
so through this work we show how virtual
robotics platforms introducing
reinforcement learning to young learners
can create authentic and adaptive
learning experiences
and increase access to robotics
education
overall today i've explored how we can
leverage voice interaction to create new
paradigms in computing education that
are appropriate for pre-literate
learners
how we can extend that approach to even
better support the learning of
computational practices
how children begin to think about and
conceptualize this kind of voice-based
ai
and how we can build on top of existing
infrastructures and computing education
to educate students about ai
in doing so i've demonstrated how
cognitively appropriate and readily
accessible computing education tools
support children's engagement and
learning of core ideas in computing
and i'll be happy to take any questions
[Applause]
so for the purposes of creating a
research prototype we're building
something that's kind of robust enough
for 50 participants in user study
to then go on and release that publicly
would require a lot more development
work which
is in process but it hasn't happened
i'll also mention that a lot of the kind
of
back-end speech processing that happens
runs on right now google cloud and we
chose that because that's the system and
software that best understands young
children's voices
but to then release that publicly every
kind of speech text translation we do
and text-to-speech costs money so for
the purpose of our 50 participants it's
like six dollars but if we were to
release it publicly it would be used by
a lot of people potentially it could get
really expensive very quickly
yeah
so one really cool thing in all the
research
of many different modalities
like
and i'm serious both completely in the
ar example did you see any specific
evidence that having that the ar
track was was more was valuable compared
to just having to see the keys
like if there's anything actually they
got out of that and also more generally
what are other modalities you're
interested in exploring for other
computational thinking or learning
experiences that haven't been as
widespread
yeah so
for the purposes of the study that we
ran we weren't able to test the ar
features and that was a deliberate
choice because in order to use those ar
features you have to have a really
up-to-date ipad
but we wanted to make sure that we were
could be more inclusive participants and
we emphasized or focused our recruitment
on that
so to run those studies we
if students had the ipad or the laptop
that could run
our software then that's how we ran the
studies but for students who didn't we
were able to screen share a simulator of
an ipad
and allow them to interact that way
so in the study we ran we actually
weren't able to test the ar features
there's some prior work that shows
increased engagement when children
learners learn and use var but that's
actually one of the future directions
that i'm excited pursuing is kind of how
we can better integrate ar and then
study ar in an educational context
all right can you hear me
yes
great um i've just noticed that a lot of
the
um
what do you call it the voices that were
in the
ai speech software were i guess more
artificial um and maybe have had the
cadence that might not be necessary for
a human
uh do you think the
this generated text of speech may have
impacted you know children's ability to
differentiate on like
whether
this thing was like of a shared mind or
not um because it's
it kind of sounds like it's clearly
um
an ai generated voice
yeah so there's a few different voices
we heard in the presentation today so in
the software apps the story coder apps
that children use those were google's
text-to-speech voice in the first app
which is quite artificial sounding and
then the second app used google's
wavenet voices which actually sound a
lot more realistic for the purpose of
the video i sped it up so you weren't
listening to a very slow agent talk
so in speeding it up it became a lot
more artificial
those wavenet voices are
surprisingly realistic and are the
voices that are on google homes for
instance
so
as to whether those artificial voices
would impact children's understanding
it's quite possible
but
even with that distinction so even if
children are using
or are recognizing that there's a
difference in this voice from a regular
human voice what our data is showing is
that they're not reasoning about these
devices
kind of differently than they do from a
human mind which is actually really
surprising for us
does that answer your question
yeah it does perfect
okay um i think an interesting time
because the class is over we'll uh wrap
here and i think griffin will stay
around for a few minutes and take a few
questions and then the committee's gonna
move to a
private uh meeting so um thank you
griffin and congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]